after completing my B Tech in civil
engineering I started working in the
same field but after six months I
realized that I was not happy or
satisfied in my job that's when I came
across the field of data science and
decided to upskill myself I chose simply
learned Advanced certificate program in
data science in partnership with Purdue
University it was the best decision I
could have made for my career the course
equipped me with the right skills to
enter into the field of my dreams as a
complete fresher in data science I was
able to secure a job as a data scientist
with a 400 increment in my salary
hi I'm Danish I'm working as a data
scientist at Sutherland Global in
Bangalore I took the advanced
certificate program in data science from
Simply learn in partnership with Purdue
University
my experience with simply learn has been
fantastic
the course is designed in such a way as
to slowly groom you on the basic
concepts to the advanced ones
it contained many industry relevant
projects which is extremely important to
get Hands-On skills one of the best
features is that it has a blended
learning of both line lectures and
self-paced learning which enabled me to
study according to my own schedule
post gave me the confidence and
ammunition to pursue the field of data
science of which I knew very little off
I was able to secure the job as a data
scientist at Southern and Global in
Bangalore with the 400 increment in my
salary
upskilling is crucial and everyone
should prioritize it the job market
changes rapidly so staying up to date
with the latest trends and Technologies
is important by upskilling you increase
your worth your current employer and
open up more new job opportunities in
the long term I want to learn all that
is in the field of data science it is a
very vast and exciting field which I
explore more and more every day I want
to work on great projects and build my
portfolio knowledge base before I can
move on to start my own data analytics
company someday
so if you are considering upskilling I
highly recommend you to go for it
without wasting any time it was the best
decision I could have made for my career
and I am sure it can be yours too
thank you